[music]
>> This is Mishkat al-Masabih, again a very
good book, but again
this book also person when someone
quotes to you a Hadith from Mishkat.
And then it says it's a compilation from
Bukhari. Preferably quote Bukhari, don't
quote Mishkat, please.
Well, Mishkat
may be Hadith sahih, may be sahih. Good
compilation.
Good for reading. Even I have quoted in
my talk Mishkat because I know that in
some people here in India, Mishkat
al-Masabih means khalas, stop. So, I use
the logic of Imam Bukhari sometimes and
even quote Mishkat al-Masabih.
But every Hadith in Mishkat al-Masabih
is not sahih.
But it's a good work.
It's a good compilation.
Hadith al-Qudsi.
110 Hadith al-Qudsi. Hadith al-Qudsi
means
Hadith came directly to Muhammad
Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam. It's a
revelation. How the verses of the Quran
came to Muhammad Sallallahu Alaihi
Wasallam. Hadith al-Qudsi are those that
came directly
to Muhammad Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam.
And all the Hadiths are sahih. Hadith
al-Qudsi has a different
category
on a higher level.
But the calamity Hadith is over. It's
not over. It's not even started yet.
So, I cannot say Hadith is over.
It is just not even scratching the
surface.
And time is limited, but just to tell
you
that we are telling you how to
use knowledge and from where to use.
As I told you, this is not a
knowledge-based Dawah training program.
It is technique-based. I'm just giving
you the key that when you want to use
Hadith, how do you use it? Always use
authentic Hadith as Hujjah.
Dhaif Hadith has its importance, but not
as a Hujjah.
And when you are discussing the
difference of opinion, the difference of
opinion mainly comes in the difference
of Hadith sahih or dhaif, mainly.
Then, a difference can come in
interpretation of the sahih Hadith. They
may agree to sahih,
but they may interpret in a different
way. That's another
level.
Let's not go into that now.
It will be too much to digest.
You will start wondering, is it the
course we have come here for
learning Hadith or
do not We just
scratching the surface.
The next category
is the books on the life of Prophet
Muhammad Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam.
We'll just rush through it fast.
The first amongst the good Sirahs that
available in
English language
and which is voluminous,
it is
Muhammad Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam
Encyclopedia of Sirah. It comes in eight
volumes.
This is done by the Muslim Schools Trust
in London, printed in UK. And this is a
good, mashallah,
speaking in great detail about the Sirah
of Muhammad Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam.
Ar-Raheeq al-Makhtum
also the sealed nectar
again
done by Safiur Rahman al-Mubarakpuri.
The Sheikh, alhamdulillah, also happened
to be from India.
And he expired recently. May Allah grant
him Jannah. He's done a great work.
There was a competition on writing
books on the biography of the Prophet
Muhammad Sallallahu alayhi wasallam
alayhi wasallam al-Islamiyah.
It was done
a couple of decades earlier.
And this book won the award for the best
book on the Seerah of the Prophet
Muhammad Sallallahu alayhi wasallam. And
it's from authentic sources,
alhamdulillah. Yet
even though
he's a great scholar, yet there are some
Dhaif Hadith that have crept in here.
So, when you say authentic, means
authentic, okay, but not
because every scholar when does the
research realizes that okay, fine, a
Dhaif Hadith I quoted without verifying
it and all. So, there are a few Dhaif
Hadith even in this, but as a whole,
it's authentic as a whole.
about the life. So, if you want to know
from authentic sources, there are many
books on the life of Prophet Muhammad
Sallallahu alayhi wasallam.
But you have to see that the book is
authentic. There are many books which
are popular, but they've quoted
even again, I don't know where to go and
where to stop. In the Seerah of Muhammad
Sallallahu alayhi wasallam, there are
two types of Seerah.
One is Seerah from history
and one is Seerah from
Hadith only. Classifications of Seerah
of the Prophet, there are two types of
books written.
One book, okay, it's a historical fact,
we wrote it down.
Maybe that may be wrong. But some
scholars say, "No, we will only take
from authentic Hadith." Means خلاص
authenticated. So, if you read books
which are taken only from authentic
sources, and one such kind of book is
this, but this is not
the one I'm talking about by the Arabic
scholars.
So, Seerah of the Prophet also you have
those group of scholars who consider the
Seerah only which are proven from the
authentic hadith. That's it.
Other scholars they have taken sahih
hadith also.
Dhaif hadith.
Also historical facts which is not
passing the test of
sahih hadith.
It has its value.
It should be there.
But
as a hujjah
we can only use
the seerah which is written only from
authentic sources. So, when you say
Quran and sahih hadith it includes the
seerah of the prophet also.
But
other books which talk about historical
facts, history has its own way of saying
right or wrong. But the science of
hadith is far superior than the science
of history.
It will take it lock, stock, and barrel.
In the historical facts, if you want to
punch holes you can punch 100.
But in the science of hadith you cannot.
If you don't know you will say who said
this said even today.
There are scholars that have got the
sanad
of Bukhari. Okay, this was Bukhari.
Bukhari wrote to so-and-so scholar.
So-and-so scholar said to so-and-so. To
so-and-so scholar. To Ziyad ibn Manzur
and from Ziyad ibn Manzur. So, if you
say that you have read Bukhari and you
have a sanad it will go to Muhammad
Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam. Muhammad
Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam to this
Sahaba, to that, to that, to that, to
that. How many generations? 50, 60, 70,
80, I don't know.
And Ziyad ibn Manzur is one of the
persons who also has the sanad and he
may give to some of his students, may
not give to some of his students.
Okay, fine. This person I testify that
he has read Bukhari very well. He has a
sanad of understanding Bukhari.
That's another.
Not just going to any university. If you
go to any university and you pass your
bachelor's degree in hadith that doesn't
mean you have that sanad. And then that
sanad is authentic or not is another
question.
Because if one rawi, one of the
[clears throat] teachers is weak, alas,
the sanad is useless.
Again.
So, many people have three, three, four
four cells. And Sheikh Zaid Zaman asked
me
even he had many cells.
He said this cell of mine most powerful.
According to him.
Even today Quran can be recited what is
right or wrong by Sunnah. You know
everything mashallah. The science of
Islam is so perfect. Alhamdulillah.
So Sira again based on
authentic Hadith is more correct, more
appealing than only based on history.
Historical facts. Is it clear?
This is again the life of Muhammad
Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam
by Tayeb Al-Isma'il. It's a good
reading.
This is again
Muhammad Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam his
life based on the earlier sources by
Martin Lings. Martin Lings also has
written a very good book mashallah.
On Muhammad Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam.
This is the life of the book by Haykal.
It's a very famous book Haykal Haykal.
This is again Sirat Ibn Hisham biography
of the prophet abridged by Abdus Salam
M. Harun.
This is abridged version.
But this again Sirat un-Nabi.
These are few books. There are many
books.
Thousands of books written on the Sira
of Muhammad Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam.
These are some of the ones that have
been translated
into English or directly written into
English. Alhamdulillah.
We have
three more sections.
Again, if I have shown you five books
that doesn't mean these five only there.
These five are few of the many books
available
in English language again. There is
difference between English and Arabic,
but naturally the best books to be
referred are the books in Arabic. They
are from authentic sources.
And they are written by scholars. Like
Arabic is far superior.
English comes as a second.
Later on English and
Urdu also has a high value because there
are many scholars in Urdu. But Arabic is
number one.
We'll come to the fourth section,
Encyclopedia on Islam. Unfortunately,
there are very few encyclopedia on Islam
available in English, very few.
And one of the oldest
we'll come to it later on.
The oldest one was by H.A.R. Gibb. It's
not available here, I think.
This encyclopedia on Islam
by E.J. Brill is from Netherlands.
And that was in eight volumes. So, it is
very expensive.
It was one of the first encyclopedia
written on Islam. Unfortunately, the
contributors, many uh most of them were
non-Muslims. So, it has an oriental
approach.
Good for student of knowledge, otherwise
no. Many things in it
may not be correct. But, it's there as a
reference book available in English. The
other one that came recently, recently
again recently means 20 years back
because recently has different
connotations.
This is the Oxford Encyclopedia of
Modern Islamic World taken out by the
Oxford Press by John Esposito. And if
you know John Esposito is a Christian
and supposed to be a scholar on Islam.
And not that I agree everything about he
says, but he's alhamdulillah he's quite
objective
and many a time truthful.
But, can't agree with everything what he
says. But,
it's a book worth reading. So, in that
encyclopedia, that's one of the
encyclopedia done by Oxford in four
volumes.
It is there, but always best is to read
from the authentic the top scholars who
are Muslims carried the bigger weight.
Unfortunately, encyclopedias
in English are hardly any.
But, this is much better than by H.A.R.
Gibb, much better.
If you want to refer in English, this is
one.
There are many which are coming lately
now in English.
This is again the Concise Encyclopedia
of of
by Cyril Glassé. I'm just telling you
because these were famous, but not that
they're authentic, please.
So, H.A.R. Gibb, you have to be careful.
I'm telling you because this was the
only one available
a couple of decades earlier. Now, these
have come out, but yet we have a lack of
books on encyclopedia in English
language.
>> [music]
[music]
[singing]